I have some great news for you today
Donald Trump's indicted and convicted
personal lawyer Michael Cohen who knows
a lot he really knows lots and lots
about the criminal conspiracy that is
the private business and political life
of Donald Trump is going to be
testifying publicly before the House
Oversight Committee before he goes to
prison this hearing is scheduled for
February 7th he is due to report to a
prison for the start of his three year
prison term in March the topics of this
hearing will include illegal hush money
payments to porn stars and models but
more importantly his lies about Donald
Trump's involvement in the Trump Tower
Moscow project which of course
ultimately didn't happen that's an area
of more and more interest Cohen himself
is saying that this hearing is going to
let him give a quote full and credible
account of the events that have
transpired and boy is there not a desire
to get that full and and 100%
transparent account I look forward to it
Donald Trump is saying that he's quote
not worried about it at all which is of
course completely not believable even a
tiny bit but I do want to sort of issue
a word of caution or a disclaimer of
sorts
I wouldn't expect Michael Cohen to show
up in open house testimony to an open
house hearing and give testimony about
the real blockbusters okay and Adam
Schiff who runs the House Intelligence
Committee remember this February 7th
hearing will be with the Oversight
Committee Adam Schiff now the Democrats
have taken over in the house runs the
House Intelligence Committee he said he
wants a full slate of answers about
Russia but that those questions and more
importantly the answers are going to
have to take place in a closed session
maybe within the Intelligence Committee
instead of the Oversight Committee so
that makes a lot of sense will Cohen's
testimony be the major blockbuster that
some people are hoping for I really
don't know when we look at history
congressman Elijah Cummings pointed out
that in 1973 when John Dean testified in
the Watergate investigation that was a
watershed moment as Elijah Cummings
described it which eventually led to I
mean you can say it was one of the
catalysts for the resignation of
President Richard Nixon
so that's possible 73 was very different
than 2019 right the partisan media
dynamic that we have right now which
exists to shield Trump no matter what
the partisan nature of the Senate above
and beyond what we had in the 1970s is
different my expectation is that there
are real bombshells that Michael Cohen
can deliver can provide information
about but that we are unlikely to get
them in public on February 7th in front
of the House Oversight Committee I would
assume that Cohen's lawyers wouldn't
even allow him to do that to talk about
that in public because they'd be afraid
of Republicans saying Cohen is
interfering with ongoing investigations
and maybe causing even more legal
trouble but if what Cohen says in
private if there is indeed a hearing
with the House Intelligence Committee
behind closed doors if it's explosive
you will hear about it from Democrats on
these two House committees Cohen
testifying February 7th I would
anticipate February 6th might be a
perfect day for Donald Trump to formally
declare a national emergency around
immigration right I mean a perfect way
to distract from what's going on we will
see the outrageous Trump tweets we will
see some whacky executive order maybe
even a blank piece of paper being signed
on social media we will see the
emergency declaration maybe a public
threat of military action against the
country all in the 72 hours before
Michael Cohen's testimony but testimony
and it is going to be a wild a wild next
30 days we will be covering all of it
and I really look forward to hearing
from Michael Cohen about this issue one
of the days sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman which is a free service
that I myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects
your actual debit card so that it's not
spread all over the internet and one of
the best things about it is how their
mobile app and browser extensions for
Chrome and Firefox make it really easy
to use let's say for example that I'm
signing up for a david pakman show
membership in the credit card number
field I already see the privacy comm
icon I just click it choose which of my
virtual credit cards I want to use and
the credit card number expiration date
and security code are automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy calm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link